y
[Música]
la f de ahí el centro para el control de
enfermedades de estados unidos
recomendaron pausar el uso de la vacuna
de johnson y johnson esto tras
registrarse de seis casos de mujeres que
presentaron coágulos en la sangre una de
ellas falleció y otra se encuentra en
estado crítico
la farmacéutica anunció que retrasará
sus entregas en europa
irán comenzará a enriquecer uranio al
60% más cerca del 90 por ciento
necesario para fabricar armas nucleares
esto tras el sabotaje contra la planta
de natanz por el que señala a israel
teherán dice que el ataque fortalece sus
posiciones de cara a una nueva ronda de
diálogo en viena para salvar el acuerdo
nucleares de 2015 tenemos reporte
y siguen en aumento las tensiones rusia
ucrania
moscú envió 15 buques al mar negro y le
advirtió a eeuu que mantenga sus barcos
de guerra
lejos de la anexada crimea en bruselas
de la otan le exigió al kremlin que
retire sus tropas de la zona limítrofe y
el presidente joe biden e propuso a su
homólogo vladimir putin una cumbre en un
tercer país
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y a partir de este momento los
acompaño con las noticias este martes la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos y el centro para el control
y la prevención de enfermedades de eeuu
solicitaron pausar el uso de la vacuna
de johnson y johnson en el país el
anuncio llega después de que la fd a
registrar a seis casos de coágulos
graves y extraños en seis mujeres de 50
años tras recibir la inyección una de
ellas perdió la vida y otro está en
estado crítico el informe es de alva
santana
un nuevo revés para los intentos por
frenar la pandemia este martes la fed y
el cdc de estados unidos recomendaron
suspender el uso de las dosis
desarrolladas por el laboratorio janssen
filial de la multinacional johnson and
johnson tras registrar casos de
coagulación sanguínea
hoy la fda y el cdc emitimos una
declaración sobre la vacuna del cuvi 19
de johnson and johnson recomendamos una
pausa en el uso de esta vacuna por
precaución de los 68 millones de
personas que han recibido las dosis de
janssen en eeuu fueron 6 mujeres menores
de 50 años las que registraron coágulos
graves y extraños una de ellas han
muerto y otra está en estado grave no
obstante la fed ha remarcado que la
gente no debe tener miedo ya que los
beneficios de la vacuna son mucho
mayores a los riesgos desde la casa
blanca han asegurado que este percance
no afectará la vacunación nacional ni al
objetivo de joe biden de aplicar 200
millones de dosis en sus primeros 100
días
por precaución la fda y el cdc han
recomendado una pausa en la vacuna de
johnson and johnson tenemos suministros
más que suficientes de facer y modernas
para continuar con el ritmo actual de
vacunación de 3 millones de inyecciones
diarias tras la noticia la compañía ha
decidido retrasar la distribución de
dosis en europa
allí la ema empezó a investigar las el
viernes bajo sospechas de coagulación
aunque ha remarcado que no hay ninguna
relación clara entre la vacuna y los
casos de trombos la vacuna de janssen es
de las pocas que se aplican una sola
dosis por lo que es vista como un arma
para frenar la pandemia sobre todo en
los países con menos recursos para
neutralizar el hobbit 19 usa un virus
conocido como adenovirus y tiene una
eficacia del 66 9% su suspensión
temporal podría afectar al ritmo de
vacunación mundial
el gobierno de francia denunció la
suspensión de los vuelos con brasil en
un intento por evitar la expansión de la
variante de coronavirus identificada en
ese país que además es actualmente el
foco mundial de la enfermedad lo dijo el
primer ministro galo jean castex durante
un debate en el cual la asamblea
nacionales discutirá medidas para
contener el virus hasta ahora los
pasajeros procedentes de brasil debían
argumentar que su viaje era de primera
necesidad y presentar una prueba pcr
negativa para poder ingresar al país
detalles desde parís con nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz
el primer ministro son castex anunció la
suspensión de vuelos o con brasil hasta
nueva orden francia había mantenido
algunos vuelos entre ambos países con un
protocolo sanitario reforzado como la
presentación de un texto bcr negativo de
menos de 72 horas pero para muchos en
especial los diputados de oposición esta
era una medida que no era suficiente
además había que tener en cuenta la
situación sanitaria de brasil que cada
día viene agravándose además de esto se
suma la preocupación de los médicos
franceses por esta variante brasilera
llamada p 1 según un estudio realizado
por la asociación brasilera de cuidados
intensivos y que publicó los resultados
hace unos días pues esta variante es
mucho más contagiosa afecta más a los
jóvenes y puede ser resistente a las
vacunas los médicos en francia temen a
pesar de que esta variante por ahora
representa sólo el 5% de los contagios
actualmente pues que llegue a una cuarta
ola de contagios mucho más letal que la
que se está viviendo actualmente por
cuenta de la variante británica
en otras noticias se irán anunció al
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica que comenzará a enriquecer
uranio a un 60 por ciento de pureza la
cifra ya preocupa pues se acerca al 90
por ciento necesario para producir
armamento nuclear el anuncio llegó de
boca del negociador nuclear del país a
barack si un día después del ataque que
dejó sin electricidad la planta de
enriquecimiento de natanz causando daños
en los equipos
teherán responsabiliza a israel y lo
acusa de terrorismo nuclear la república
islámica ya estaba enriqueciendo uranio
al 20 por ciento en ruptura de los
compromisos adquiridos en el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 que fue abandonado por
eeuu en 2018 y que actualmente se
renegocia en viena para levantar las
sanciones internacionales
nos enviamos una carta al oiea diciendo
que vamos a agregar mil centrifugadoras
más a la instalación nuclear de natanz
también hoy acabamos de enviar una nueva
carta a la agencia diciendo que
comenzamos a partir de mañana con un
enriquecimiento de hasta el 60% eso es
para las necesidades de irán de producir
ciertos radioisótopos para ciertos
tratamientos médicos por su parte el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia serguéi lávrov llegó a teherán y
se reunió con el presidente de hassan
row jan y también conversó con el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
mohamad yavad sharif el canciller iraní
y calificó como una muy mala apuesta el
supuesto ataque a la instalación nuclear
de natanz del que culpa a israel
asimismo aseguró que lo ocurrido
fortalecería la posición de teherán de
cara a una nueva ronda de diálogos en
viena para reactivar el acuerdo nuclear
no tenemos ningún problema en volver a
implementar los los compromisos del
pacto líder pero los estadounidenses
deben saber que ni las sanciones ni los
actos de sabotaje les darán herramientas
de negociación y estos actos sólo les
dificultará la situación
bernanke para profundizar en la noticia
las conversaciones con nuestra
corresponsal en teherán ha de catalina
gómez ángela
un saludo y porque teherán asegura que
el ataque a natanz fortalece su posición
en la renegociación del acuerdo nuclear
tampoco es coherente para salvar el
pacto el anuncio de aumentar al 60 por
ciento de pureza el enriquecimiento con
uranio
bueno desde el punto de vista del gran
cada vez que han aumentado
su programa nuclear lo han hecho más
fuerte ellos han visto como desde otras
partes del mundo especialmente las
grandes estas grandes potencias con las
que firmaron el acuerdo nuclear han
reaccionado y han buscado tener un
acuerdo con ellos recordemos que ese
pacto nuclear se hizo en el 2015 con el
objetivo de prolongar en el tiempo ese
progreso del programa nuclear y a tener
muchos de esas sectores de ese programa
así que ellos ven que habrán más
necesidades de esos países si realmente
temen como dicen que avances del
programa nuclear iraní usted hablaba de
que ahora enriquecerá el horario al 60
por ciento esté aquí al salto al 90 por
ciento es muy poco y lancia había dicho
que ellos no buscan un programa de
armamento nuclear pero uno de los
objetivos de ese acuerdo nuclear era
hacer que fuera cada vez más difícil que
irán enriquecerá uranio a ese nivel
tanto así que cuando se firmó el acuerdo
había el límite era 3.67 por ciento el
cual obviamente ya pasaron hace
muchísimo tiempo además los otros países
saben que cada vez es más difícil la
posición del gobierno iraní que aunque
quiere volver a ese acuerdo los más
radicales se oponen así que esas
negociaciones de política interna
también son más difíciles para desde el
punto de vista de los países que
negocian con irán
bueno catalina justamente las cifras del
60 por ciento es preocupante el país
está un 30 por ciento por debajo de la
capacidad para armas nucleares va a
despertar estos represalias de israel
bueno las represalias han estado ahí
angela desde siempre recordemos que este
no es el primer sabotaje o ataque contra
el programa nuclear iraní hacer un ayuno
junio del 2020 hubo un incendio un
ataque a las plantas exteriores de esta
misma planta de natanz y meses después
fue asesinado que será considerado por
las inteligencias occidentales como en
la cabeza de ese programa nuclear iraní
y ya más atrás también habían habido más
sabotajes o sea que esto
probablemente no será ni el uno en el
último de estos ataques de israel
obviamente que en la medida que irán va
avanzando en ese programa enriquece
uranio a mayor porcentaje obviamente se
siente más nervioso solo hace unas pocas
horas se anunció que irán había atacado
es lo que se dice son todavía rumores un
barco de israelí de bandera israelí que
estaba en las aguas del golfo pérsico un
poco y que había aunque los daños fueron
pequeños pues esto es lo que estamos
viendo
estamos viendo represalias de un lado d
otro que seguramente van a continuar
gracias catalina rusia ha trasladado una
flota de 15 buques al mar negro en una
nueva movida amenazante contra ucrania
las tensiones escalaron de nuevo desde
la anexión de la península de crimea por
vladimir putin desde eeuu el presidente
giovanni de nl propuso al jefe del
kremlin una cumbre en un tercer país y
es que el ambiente es de una frontera
tensa y con tropas al lado y lado de los
países la movilización de flota marítima
llegó como respuesta al reciente anuncio
de eeuu que comunicó que dos de sus
buques de guerra llegaran al mar negro
esta semana como muestra de apoyo a kiev
justamente este martes durante una
reunión con el ministro de exteriores
ucraniano en bruselas el secretario
general de la otan ha de jens
stoltenberg pidió a rusia que retire sus
tropas y que le ponga fin a lo que
calificó como una provocación
la acumulación de tropas por parte de
rusia es injustificado en explicado y
profundamente preocupante rusia debe
poner fin a esta expansión militar en la
frontera con ucrania detener las
provocaciones y es escalar la situación
inmediatamente en tikrit
el líder de la casa blanca- joe biden
habría establecido la fecha del 11 de
septiembre de 2021 en el vigésimo
aniversario de los ataques terroristas
en nueva york y el pentágono para el
retiro total de las tropas de
estadounidenses presentes en afganistán
esto según una fuente consultada por la
agencia de noticias reuters que quiso
mantener su anonimato los secretarios de
estado- anthony blinken y de defensa al
oído hostiles serían los encargados de
comunicar la decisión a la otan este
miércoles en bruselas de confirmarse el
retiro de las 2500 tropas en septiembre
no se cumpliría con la fecha del primero
de mayo
previamente propuesta por la
administración de donald trump lo que
podría implicar una retoma de las
hostilidades por parte de los talibanes
y en japón las autoridades aprobaron las
liberaciones de más de un millón de
toneladas de agua contaminada de la
planta nuclear de fukushima devastada
por un terremoto y posterior tsunami en
2011 al océano pacifico aunque el
gobierno asegura que el agua sería
tratada para reducir los niveles de
radiación el hecho ya genera protestas
tanto de activistas como de
representantes de la industria pesquera
veamos
no pongan en peligro el futuro de
nuestros hijos activistas antinucleares
se manifestaron frente al parlamento
japonés rechazan el plan del gobierno de
verter el agua contaminada de la central
nuclear de fukushima al océano pacífico
diez años después del tsunami que
provocó el desastre las reacciones en
cadenas siguen afectando a los reactores
dañados y el complejo casi no tiene
espacio para almacenar el agua de
refrigeración que se acumula a un ritmo
de 170 toneladas diarias el agua
contaminada se filtra primero antes de
ser almacenada pero el dispositivo no
tiene la capacidad de eliminar el trillo
un isótopo radiactivo del hidrógeno
por debajo de los límites impuestos por
las autoridades japonesas y también por
la o&m s en cuanto a las normas de
seguridad del agua potable los
científicos consideran que niveles bajos
de trillo no son peligrosos para el
medio ambiente pero los pescadores
japoneses están preocupados total
y como hemos dicho repetidamente al
gobierno que nos oponemos
categóricamente a este plan mucho
detesto los habitantes temen en efecto
las repercusiones del vertido sobre la
calidad de la industria pesquera un
sector esencial en una región ya
castigada y aunque el proceso no es
nuevo las aguas residuales que contienen
trillo se vierten regularmente en los
océanos china y corea del sur también se
muestran preocupadas por la decisión de
tokio más de un millón de toneladas de
agua de refrigeración están almacenadas
actualmente en el sitio de fukushima su
liberación en el océano podría comenzar
dentro de dos años
y veamos los titulares de nuestro sitio
web france24 puntocom en kobe de 19
comiendo en suspender en eeuu el uso de
la vacuna de johnson y johnson por casos
de trombos y en bolivia la oposición se
fortalece de frente al más en las
regiones también vea los detalles de la
información sobre irán que advirtió a la
oiea que comenzará a enriquecer uranio
al 60%
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros
[Música]